you fixing my hair do I have a gray what
are you doing what's happening oh oh
whew just a chunk alright welcome back
to the evident killing podcast real
quick shout out to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video thank you for
sponsoring and we'll hear a little bit
more on them later but today's podcast
is about the life cheat sheet this is
this is Evans life cheat sheet I am
merely a part of it you you you're an
integral part of it too but it's
something that I started out a long time
like a long I don't know it was probably
like high school all right
yeah probably around there I just don't
know say how many years that it was ago
cuz I'm counting it and I'm feeling old
but I know that there are people older
than me listening to that and I know no
one likes anyone complaining about their
age so moving on it's just I don't know
every now and then you like you have
these deep thoughts and you're oh I like
write that down and figure that out and
ponder more and try to like simplify all
of those concepts that you've had into
like a single sentence or like a single
concept and then like see how they hold
up over time so it's like what we're
gonna be sharing on this episode is like
just one of the life cheat sheets like a
single bullet point and then we'll
probably make this a reoccurring segment
and kind of like
go back to the life cheat sheet add some
more of like the things that have held
up over time and kind of like flush out
like I don't know my approach to life a
little bit thanks for the interest on so
um today's thing today's like today is
like point that we're gonna be making is
about like finding your thing and I
think that it's a fairly easy thing to
explain basically like how does your mom
describe you when she's telling you
about her friends she's telling your
friends about you oh yeah yeah how does
your mom describe you when she's talking
about you sure her friends or like when
you introduce yourself or when a
co-worker introduces you it's like
what's that thing
hey this is Kailen she likes cats that's
the thing yes thanks like you know you
have different things depending on the
context too if your mom introduces you
it might be like you're a student or
you're an athlete or thanks cats hi this
is my daughter Caitlin she likes cats if
that is your primary thing you must
really like cats I know and that's gonna
follow you around for a long time like
since it was like it is one of your
things and that's what people know about
you what's your Christmas present what's
your birthday presents it's things like
cat related measuring cups and mugs and
cat slippers lots of lots of things and
that airs on my headphones that was a
gift from you yeah but often times your
thing might be your profession it might
be like your hobbies and might be
whatever it is it might be like you are
a parent that might that's a huge thing
to so many people like a big part of
your identity like what is the thing
that makes you you like to yourself and
others yeah I think a lot of people fall
into their profession being their thing
even if it's not something that they're
super into yeah your thing can be taken
over by responsibilities you have in
life and you can like lose your thing to
your adult responsibilities oh yeah and
we almost lost gaming there is a long
time there where like I wanted to play
games but I just couldn't justify the
time and I'd like I felt that lack of my
identity you know what I mean I feel
like a lot of people who graduate from
college like struggle with what their
life is what their life means now and
now that you're not a student because
like when you're in school being a
student is so much a part of your thing
and even like within like being a
student you like are good at math or you
are part of Student Council or you're
part of a swim team or band or whatever
it is so it's like so much of your thing
is tied up into like school and once you
lose school then like you lose so many
things all at once and you're like
Who am I what am i and also you go from
like being a student to like this new
job and that's a new thing that's a new
part of your identity but it hasn't been
part of your identity up until that
moment and you've just lost all of your
previous things I think that that's
something that a lot of people struggle
with you know especially if you're your
first job maybe isn't your first choice
you know if you've been in med school
for years and you become a doctor you're
like yes I'm fulfilling my thing you
know assuming that it's something you're
passionate about yeah for both of us we
had fairly easy transitions from school
to our job with like continuity of our
thing for me it was engineering and you
know design and problem-solving all that
that that carried over pretty easily and
for you was art art yeah our art has
been your thing for the longest time as
long as cats almost cats was before art
oh yeah oh yeah okay I think so I mean I
remember being passionate about cats
long before I was good at art I was like
I remember liking cats and I was like
two and three no this is this brings up
an interesting point you said I remember
alike in cats before I was good at art
now that brings up an interesting theory
of mine do you have to be good at
something for it to be your thing
oftentimes I feel like being good at
something kind of makes it your thing
sometimes okay well first I'll say art
was my thing before I was good at it
because I had lots of older relatives
that were artists that told me I was an
excellent artist probably the same love
the belief that you are good like is
that often what leads to something
becoming your thing maybe but but a
thing your thing isn't always something
that you do yeah so let me use two of my
examples it's how can you be good at
loving cats I mean you are it's just
something you'd like and the thing you
like is your thing yeah like you could
be really into sports mm-hmm oh yeah and
that's not why new that is something you
actively do you gotta people are really
in this
that don't oh well you know watching it
that that's the way you spend your time
watching always back to the cat's okay
[Laughter]
we understand but III think that um like
being aware that you have a thin like
and maintaining it and kind of I don't
want to say curating it because that
sounds like really weird and wrong I
don't know for some reason about like
nourishing nourishing it that's it like
nourishing it like if you if you're
seeing them fade you can either
reinforce them or just like know that
there's still a part of you just don't
have the time for them anymore I just
feel like being aware of that helps
people what would you say like three of
your top things are or five of your top
things picking up yeah okay I think
primarily I I definitely think one of
our things now is our job which is
content creation but I think that like
that's a huge thing youtubing I feel
like that's a huge part of our are
things or I'll just talk about me first
so creating content is a big part of our
thing making is a huge part of my thing
and that like encompasses art and Janee
hring like video editing photo editing
just like making in general I think I
feel like you're bundling a lot into
that I feel like video editing I think
it's maybe a little different I think
art and making are they close enough to
tie I don't think so I think there's a
lot of people that are into one that
aren't into the other okay you can
making an art so so content creation
making art and like a strange thing that
like I don't talk about much if at all
anymore
is I still feel like a core part of me
as a swimmer yeah I already feel that
about you too
yeah cuz like I love swimming III I'd
love to workout like via swimming by
swam for for years and years during high
school four hours a day six days a week
it's just like still so much a part of
me even though I don't do it and I think
that's weird I think there's a tiny tiny
part of me that still consider
soccer a thing it did for eight years
yeah even though I haven't played since
late middle school what do you still
love it if you did it
probably not I just don't get sweaty
when I hop back into the pool and I'm
like swimming laps and stuff I just like
get this sense of home this is gonna
sound really weird but you know when
you're when you're in your home and
there's cozy lights on maybe a fire
there's a very home comfort vibe to like
a scenario like that and I kind of get a
similar feeling when I jump into a pool
and I'm swimming laps I just like feel
like I've returned home I think with
soccer it's it's a little bit harder
because soccer is a team sport I can't
just like grab a ball and get the same
vibes yeah yeah in the mural League for
a day people that you don't know people
I don't know I don't know I think it'd
be fun if if like if this wasn't a weird
scenario if there was like neighborhood
kids just like kicking a ball around if
I could just go like kick a ball around
but only with kids because I don't
probably be too good I don't remember
anything I need to go up against
children is is sand soccer a game right
that sounds terrible kind of dare voice
running through Sam and like you kick
sand I have enough people at our family
reunions so I get together and impromptu
soccer match okay juvenile your thing
okay maybe well maybe our niece will
eventually play soccer or something like
that and then you can like be part of it
yeah yeah yeah I still feel like I I
know some footwork what are some other
things that were a big part of your life
that aren't anymore mmm all right oh
that's sad I know but something okay
this is something that we have talked
about quite a lot video games I felt
like I
lost that thing that was a big part of
me and we've been able to bring it back
through evident gaming which I'm so
thankful for yeah that was one of them
for me too yeah and and we've tried to
kind of like justify like put systems in
place that justify you spending time on
art that sounds so like it works with
video games but I feel like like putting
a system into place where you can like
do art we kind of do have an art channel
with Evan and Caitlin like not an art
Channel but we're able to do art every
thing is so so the art that I identified
as my thing for so long I don't really
have a desire to do it anymore
it's like detailed line art character
design Wi-Fi art and it was all like
hand like detailed line art like
Photoshop coloring like visual art and
tens of hours like like maybe like 30 40
hours per piece yeah like a really long
time yeah and like I can justify doing
some types of art like you know we do
like the some resin art and acrylic
pores and stuff on the channel up and
like sooner and that's fun but it's also
just like you kind of chaotically plop
some colors and a thing and then you
call it alright you know and like I've
been able to sometimes justify doing art
for the house if it's like oh we need
some Martin on that wall
okay paint something real quick yeah
like and it's fun don't get me wrong
like it is fun to just like oh I'll just
these are kind of the colors I want and
like here's some inspiration I'll just
like whip something up but it's
different because I had never used to do
that before when I was like really into
art and drawing everyday and like I
still definitely identify you as an
artist because you're able to do things
like oh it is grab some colors and I
whip up a beautiful beautiful piece of
art and I know what you're saying like
that isn't your creation process
I still like know and believe that it's
a big part of your identity but I also
like understand and realize and
recognize that like that's not like the
identity that you had yeah you know yeah
and it's
like I said it's not really an identity
that like you have the desire to put
that much time I mean maybe it would be
fun maybe I'd have fun if I just had a
bunch of time to just like draw up a
mermaid or a fairy or like you know some
like sci-fi princess those like the kind
of stuff but you know I was yeah very
nerdy very nerdy but like it's just hard
to justify putting so much time into
something that like then just lives in a
digital file on my computer yeah and and
we've gotten some printed but like you
said like and there's something you said
to me earlier so I'm just bringing it up
here to add with the conversation I
think I remember you telling me that you
don't really want that type of art on
our walls anymore yeah I don't really
want our walls to feel like like a like
a movie poster or like book cover yeah
you know it's like the art on your walls
no there's anything wrong with that but
like I just tend to like stuff that is
slightly more abstract or landscape II I
think that another thing is that
identity that you reached like well like
the last art that you like really put a
lot of time into was like the mermaid
octopus like oh yeah mashup though
that's really cool and it's like I never
finished 60% done 80% done my vampire
squid vampire squid mermaid and I think
that that was that was definitely before
we started YouTube yeah I think we were
like in the apartment oh my gosh yeah I
don't think we even lived in this house
yet okay that was quite a long time ago
but anyways the arc that you had been on
from when you did your first Legend of
Zelda art and like mspaint
on the computer it's like that that
whole trajectory that you had been on
for 20 years or something like that 15
years yeah okay there's that 15 year
trajectory you can kind of trace all of
your art fairly linearly you know it's
like this led to this led to this led to
this and you kept on getting better and
better and better and your art style
kept on evolving but you took this break
this long break and your interests and
designs have changed and I think they're
like restarting up and experimenting and
finding like a new style that might fit
you and fit our life that's a huge time
investment like finding a whole new
style it's like ripping off a band-aid
or like poking a wound or something like
that it's kind of a little bit painful
in that way kind of looking at yourself
and your identity that closely I don't
know I've had similar moments I don't
want to talk for you but I mean it's
kind of the same for you cuz art was one
of your things - mmhmm yeah yeah and
like this is gonna sound so dramatic but
like art is such a personal thing and
it's you you put so much of yourself
into it and if it's good you're like
yeah and if it's bad I have like
definitely like made bad art and I'm
like oh my gosh I suck Who am I I'm like
an impostor I'm not even an artist like
why do I even think of myself as an
artist if I can't even like I remember
there's this one piece of art that I
wanted to do like cliff walls on the
left and right side with a river going
down between them and like a sunset
behind it and I was trying to paint that
like just like an original thought from
my head onto the canvas
and it's uh it sucked so bad I still
might have it just like a slab of shame
and our closets over here it was so
painful I'm any question if I even am an
artist I had those moments it's also the
similar thing happens when you're on
deviantART and then you're like you see
something amazing then you realize
they're 15 or 10 years younger than you
and you're like good comparison is the
thief of joy yeah so I guess art is one
of our things that were so working in
Kersal definitely conflicted about yeah
like it's still a part of our identity
it's still somewhat active but it's
definitely like taking a back burner
taking a back burner
yeah I mean I try to like and I do
believe that creating videos is kind of
definitely a creative process you know
there's a process but I think it's
different
it's not art it's not art in the sense
of like it's not art in the same way
that the art we identified with yeah are
there like different types of creative
same Eugene's coming out video that
could be considered art but even that's
not the same you can't say like like if
I'm if I used to draw as old fan art all
the time I'm super passionate about
Zelda fan art and then I made a really
cinematic dance music video like Eugene
didn't yeah and we're talk about Eugene
from the try guys by the way if you guys
haven't seen the video those are totally
different endeavors yeah and it's not
saying one is more art than the other
they're just different types of skills
and processes even just like drawing
versus painting yeah I can't really
granular about it yes you were more
painting and I was more drawing yeah and
you've you've moved over a little bit
towards painting because it looks better
on the walls yeah so so that's kind of
our our thing theory I mean I think that
it's kind of hopefully you understand
what we're saying now when we talk about
like having a thing like what is your
thing and and kind of like losing your
thing or like shifting what your thing
is I think it's it's an interesting
thing to like self-analyze yourself with
it makes me really grateful that we have
been able to bring back videogames as a
thing we like rekindled a thing and it's
also like I I don't require having all
of my things be present in my life at
all times yeah you know it's like
there's only so much space in life I
think you like a couple things I'm
pretty good I think they're like maybe
having like one professional one
personal might be good to get you like I
mean I'm not gonna put like yeah right
yeah there's a description on it and
yeah you're right it depends wildly on
like about your job at all but you have
a love for travel and an awesome dog
yeah those are two things and your job
doesn't have to be the most fulfilling
thing it's interesting um this kind of
makes me think of the like like follow
you you know bring it back to jobs and
follow your passion yeah oh yeah yeah I
meant to talk about this type thing
every time I say thing now I'm you know
but yeah there was this like huge push
at some point like follow your path
I think that's what a lot of people our
generation like follow your passion yeah
which I mean like and we both kind of
did I think so but although within
reason but also both of us followed what
we were good at
we followed but we were good at and we
we followed our passion within reason
yes straight-up followed our passion I
would be like trying to do art
commissions in a very specific style and
topic I think that like if you follow
your passion you wouldn't be doing art
commissions you would be doing your own
art that's getting paid for it so that's
true magically yeah magic selling prints
are selling designs or something like
that yeah that is but that like if you
were just like a hundred percent like
I'm just gonna follow my hundred seven
passion it just be like doing your own
original art having people tell you what
to do is that's true it's hard
especially for art yeah I've done it
I've done Commission's before but did
you love it okay so I was being too
practical you're right if I was just
straight up following what my passion
was at the time well actually that was
like my passion in high school I kind of
stopped drawing it was it wasn't because
of YouTube really it was close of
college yeah you're surrounded by your
friends all the time in college and it's
like well I can hang out with my friends
I can do homework
I can sleep or I can draw and drawing
got cut via the whole like fall out your
your passion thing it's a really
interesting piece of advice because like
the thing we're doing now isn't
something like when I was graduating
high school I would have thought that
I'd be passionate about so I think
there's also an element of being like
open and flexible to trying new things
insane seeing if you're good about it
and seeing if you have a passion for it
but I think that one thing that is
interesting is we are going for a walk
the other day and we realize that both
of us before we started YouTube before
we did any of this we both had blogs we
were both sharing things online we both
loved creating things and sharing them
online you know and that was a thing
that we had passion for but we just
never even let ourselves consider that
it was a thing because it wasn't a job
and it wasn't something that a lot of
people identified with there weren't
the bloggers or youtubers or whatever
and there were bloggers back then I
guess not like professional ones though
really not really in high school not
really yeah
and so that's that's one thing that like
never became a thing because we didn't
let it because it we just never thought
about it in that way yeah well I guess
like so you know if I was sharing art
online I thought the thing was the art
not sharing oh yeah
but looking back I realized that sharing
it online and getting feedback and
interacting with other artists and stuff
like that was a huge part of the draw
but it's just not something I like
registered fully yeah in a moment and
interestingly enough like with the video
games I feel like the sharing it with
people sharing it online like streaming
it and then sharing the highlights
afterwards that makes the games more fun
to me and more enjoyable it just kind of
almost enhances the whole experience and
maybe it's because of the same thing you
know like sharing it with others and
joining in with others in this community
is a big part of all of this for us I
think the same for the main channel
projects and stuff so the video we just
released Friday is the resin planets so
that's something that like I feel like I
might have had a hard time justifying
just making this random thing just for
the sake of making it if we weren't
doing it for the video like it was
really fun and I'm glad we did it and
they turned out really cool but I think
knowing that we were gonna be sharing it
with people I made it worth the time you
know that that's a project that's kind
of inherently fun and experimental
anyway but even things like the Attic
project which like isn't the most fun
spending a bunch of time in a sweaty
attic even that was more fun knowing
that like we're not just doing the
project we're also making a video that
we get to share with people yeah right
yeah all right well I think that might
be a good place to wrap up the thing I
think kind of like diving into this and
analyzing it with you okay because like
these are things we've been talking
about between the two of us yeah and I
hope that you guys enjoyed this too like
let us know in the comments below if you
enjoyed the live cheat sheet we have
we've a bunch more cheat sheet we have
we have a whole bunch more about chichi
bullets and I would love to share this
with you but I think right now what I
want to share with you is Squarespace
you know what we're making another
website right now Evan and Caitlin
gaming comm and when we went to make
that new website the very first thing we
thought about was Squarespace because
it's because it's easy we were able to
like like start designing right away we
chose a good template you know we know
that it has all the plugins that we need
like already built into the website you
don't need to download any third-party
things our websites are always up and
running and if we ever run into any
troubles there's always 24 hour support
yeah yeah so because of that is super
low maintenance and because you can try
it for free it's super low pressure so
if you guys want to try it out go to
squarespace.com you can start your free
trial and if you decide that you want to
move forward and you know keep going
with your website and make purchase
officially you can use code or you can
use the URL squarespace.com slash
evident caitlin podcast to get 10% off
your first order nice read all right
guys it's game time
all right let's let's try to like name
this segment this game type and and see
if it makes sense to each other so my
name is yahood I didn't prepare for this
part I didn't think I'd have to be
creative with the name because we're
borrowing this game concept from another
podcast to try guys what basically the
concept of the game is we just go to
Yahoo Answers we type in a word any word
and then we answer whatever question
pops up yeah yeah so kind of like what
about Yahoo roulette yahoo ruled that
that's a good one okay I don't know what
they called it on the try guys podcast
but it was fun and we want to do that
too do you want to do that thing okay
then what's your word Jack no I was
gonna say whiskers whiskers okay so I
say the word you type it in and pick a
question yes
all right Kaelyn this is a great
question for you why do cats have
whiskers oh it's so when they're well I
mean there's a few reasons one it's so
if they're going through small opening
they can sense the width of the opening
oh and also I heard this and I don't
know if it's true but when a cat like
looks down and they're about to get like
a bug or something its whiskers go like
a cone they go straight down around the
ground the bug like a cone oh did you
know that cats can get whisker fatigue
what like that like like a muscle strain
I just learned about this recently on
reddit because the question was like why
doesn't my cat ever finish their food on
the bowl and it's not that like oh the
food got stale and they got tired of it
think it whisker fatigue and so when
their faces down in a deep bowl for too
long
like their whiskers are super sensitive
and it can be like just way too much
sensitivity and so they stopped eating
because their face being down in that
bowl is too sensitive yeah and so they
actually I want to get these for jube
like wide balls they sell whisker
fatigue free Bowl I have some like that
I want to get oh I'm so cute I know okay
so another thing that I've heard is that
whiskers on cats are as why
does their body yes they know that like
if they can fit their head in this is
why does her body and they know they can
fit their body what if you're really
wide we should test it I'm the
supervisor wide we should test it on a
bill and Bret Scott oh yeah oh yeah
collection dat booty cat alright given
my word is a question oh god does
Slender Man poop Slender Man and you
might need to explain Slender Man for
anyone Slender Man is like an urban
legend and like it's actually and
actually got like really creepy there
for a while like people really start
believing in Slender Man and things got
weird basically Slender Man is really
creepy
urban legend of like a really tall guy
in a suit and he just like slowly sneaks
up behind you and all of a sudden you
turn around and he's right there yeah
there's a really creepy Slender Man game
that's stressful oh so does Slender Man
poop no because he doesn't exist at all
until you turn around and he's there
what if what if he has to hold his poops
poop my own pants too he's like always
following you around cuz maybe it's like
urgent so he's trying to he's got to get
like real close to you so that you sent
something and turn around
ah I get it he can exist yeah mustache
should I pluck my girl mustache hmm I
mean I think it's an urban legend that
if you like pull out hairs they'll grow
back darker so I mean if you want to
pluck your mustache you you can or you
can just embrace it you could pull it
jenna Marbles and get some just for men
and like enhance it I feel like it's you
know maybe you'll start to do truth
all right my word is Yolo okay should I
get the word yellow or the whole
sentence you only live once
tattoo and wear no you should you the
answer is I answer yeah you answer okay
you put the word I pick the question you
answer you should get the just though
the letters Yolo on your foot so that no
one ever sees it like on the bottom of
your foot on the bottom of your foot
what if you're relaxing on the beach
okay so if you have to get okay so this
is the thing if you have to either get
Yolo or you only live once
tattooed I'd go for Yolo because
eventually Yolo might mean something
different yeah and you can explain it
away if you tattoo you only live once on
your body it forever mean that you know
so I think the opposite oh really I
think you should go with you only live
once because that's a more timeless
sentence like sentiment you know you
only live once that's something everyone
can agree with you put yellow on there
people no even if it changes meaning
it's gonna change to something else
trendy okay so you only live once are
you gonna put it on your wrist so you
see it are you gonna put it on your like
you only live on your knuckles so that
like when you're about to punch someone
you you you they will understand this is
the only life they have and they're
about to be knocked out no I think you
should put it tattooed say something
really morbid what about under your butt
cheek flap you're questioning your life
you just like lift up your butt cheek oh
yeah what is your word Bigfoot
Kevin why do people believe in Bigfoot
and where can you find 101 isn't like
there's multiple yeah yeah yeah there
could be multiple Bigfoot's this is a
race as a race of people called the big
feet
I thought Bigfoot was like a singular
entity well people have been seeing
Bigfoot for years that must mean that he
has a long life oh yeah he's a mythical
creature
he travels okay yeah okay okay so
there's only one but Bigfoot so what
what what is well why do people believe
in Bigfoot and where can you find him I
mean people believe in him because they
have large hairy friends I go pee in the
middle of the night when they're camping
so where can you find them just go
camping with a hairy frog bring as many
of them as you can yeah light up your
chances yeah and then you forget that
what you even brought one and you're
like oh my gosh that's Bigfoot and you
don't think oh that's Fred Fred's around
somewhere okay Halon so the search firm
is fish and the question is why does
fish taste bad and I'm not gonna answer
that I'm gonna answer one of the
questions that pop or ask you one of the
questions that popped up instead when
you search that and it was why doesn't
my toothbrush taste bad why does your
toothbrush taste bad why does it well
you're looking into the question for
more context I got into a fight with my
wife and every time I do this the
through the brush thing happens I can't
figure it out well you eat a lot of
garlic in a year so every time he gets
in the fight with his wife his
toothbrush tastes bad why does it happen
well I mean she's definitely
contaminating it it could be with a
maybe it's fish who she's putting his
toothbrush on fish yeah it's good it
comes full circle back to your fish
question she just gets like anchovies
like a can of anchovies that she keeps
in the back of the fridge and she dipped
I think that that sounds pretty horrible
honestly yeah but I mean that's probably
what she's doing they're getting in a
fight toothbrush tastes bad where did
this come up for for why is fish why
does fish tanks matter cuz that's the
answer someone answered it someone
already answered it correct
that's why I'm going to fish okay my
sermon is Canada does Canada have a
military and let me let me reproduce
that a military um I li er wanna try to
have a military sure they do and they're
really apologetic about it they're
really sorry about it and and their
their primary weapon is apologies and
they Raul ride horses and they they all
have a backpack full of maple syrup a
whole backpack whole backpacks
it's pressurized and like if anyone
comes by them they'll I do like like
I've seen like a Canadian military
person just like hit a beaver at 90
meters away at 90 meters heading the
beaver right in the tail I've seen it
myself
the Canada's military is dangerous and
they're not afraid to douse it
syrup yeah what sir but what's their
military I called the Royal Canadian
military they might have a mounted unit
I feel like I feel like there has to be
something right there has to be right
know this but it's just Canada's so
peaceful compared to everyone else it
started to picture that I mean I'm sure
that they do that's and like a standing
army and stuff like that right I'm sure
they do
well like Canada gets along with
everybody in Canada its Cameron what's
Canada yeah but I mean you know maybe
it's a secret military oh the Canada
milah underground military yeah yeah
that's heard rumors I thought you said I
think you saw a beaver getting shot down
what do you mean you've heard rumors it
guys that's they're just they're Scouts
you know there are many other unit types
you know okay there's the scouts and
then there's the underground military
yeah yeah do they travel through ancient
maple root tunnels no they have an army
of beavers that build all just beavers
millions of beavers you know what
they've been mechanized - yeah the
mechanized beaver unit the MB the mbu's
yep I've heard I've heard I've heard
reports through the grapevine the
dangerous that's pretty terrifying Mike
also compressor yeah I will not question
for you okay hilarious next page next
page
alright Kailen Kailen searched speedo on
Yahoo Answers there are some great ones
great ones that we cannot answer
[Laughter]
high-tech swimsuit advice weed oh I've
heard about the high-tech swimsuit
there's a lot of like people having a
very particular problem with speedos
well I mean I think you got that is I
was gonna go with the high-tech one okay
okay okay I know what high-tech speedo
they're talking about cuz I used to swim
as you might have heard earlier in the
pod oh you had a high-tech high-tech
speedo
so it had um in-flight calls in swim
calls you know in flight
no no what a hat is that bluetooth so I
could listen to songs while I swam you
have to fly I'm not sure if like United
Airlines without me on their plane just
wearing a speedo you don't have to just
I mean you get better signal if you're
just wearing a speedo but you could put
clothes over it is like dampens your
reception dampens it so so does this
feat oh let me fly or do I go on
airplanes in it he's gone airplanes in
it and you get you get like online Wi-Fi
just attacked me okay so tell me more
about this high-tech speedo so you can
make calls using it
yeah you can make calls and it gives you
reception even while you're flying even
while you're flying that's like the main
benefit this is one incredibly long
antenna that you attach to your phone
that gives you instant cancer cancer
instant cancer it's just like a hundred
percent radiation through your body no
nope no it's just cause you're wearing
it doesn't mean you're gonna get cancer
it's very high-tech how else is it the
hi-tech so it also you can take pictures
with it oh no where's the camera Caitlin
where's the camera
there's no good answer here
[Laughter]
it's 4k oh this is a high-tech camera
potato resolution are from the speedos
of the past
it's the 2019 high tech speedo the high
tech speedo yeah it also has hmm you can
listen to music okay so does have
bluetooth and how does it get the sound
into your ears it's a bone transferring
it goes the bones hamstrings through
your hips up through your hips off your
entire body pass all the fat and
everything and then it rings your head
loud enough that it hears an ear that's
perfect Katelyn
[Laughter]
you definitely what if this Peter
discovers your entire head and it covers
your ears to an ass where the the bone
transmitter speakers are that well that
would be like a swim cap no no the
speedo can like be more than just the
tiny speedo speedo is like not just the
tiny little one it's like you can get a
whole suit of Speedos well speedo is
like a brand like speedo girl swimsuits
like what your pieces for swimming well
we would call like like I mean they were
people say speedo you know what they're
talking about you're getting into
specifics and like yeah you're the high
tech speedo is a high tech speedo speedo
okay then do you think I've ever worn a
speedo
like a speedo speedo I know you've won
jammers do you think I want to speed
those fees yes I did how old were you
that was swimming or was it when you
were a little um no there's no swimming
I think I I wore speedos like multiple
times when I was like I don't know 14
and then I I also wore some during
summer leagues once a while ago but like
yeah it's great comments okay it's
pretty common swimming yeah yeah okay so
do only tell you why this high-neck
speedo actually is sure let me guess
it's actually like um it's like a
special kind of material that like has
less drag yeah pretty much that but
what's interesting is they studied
sharks and like dolphins and porpoises
and stuff like that so it's not just
like low low drag because there are lots
of patches of low drag but in certain
areas there's actually more drag and it
creates like flowing patterns as you
swim it like moves the water in a way
they're like creates kind of a little
bit of a wake and there's like it's not
like the little thing no I think enough
on my swim team we had like multiple
levels of the fancy suit depending on
how good you were
you got like more of it it's like it's
like if you were pretty good you got the
high Dex Pinot from the waist down you
know it's like swim pants yeah and I
like reduces like the drag and a lot of
ways but adds like because they're
kicking you want to push against the
water in some ways so it's like if you
are like okay you got the pants speedos
if you're pretty good you got the
overall speedos and I think that that's
that's all we had the budget for I think
the overall speedos were one of the some
of the best vetoes it was it's so tight
so tight and imagine using the restroom
like being in a wetsuit but like if you
had to take it off to pee yeah but it's
you peed in yours no no you're not
supposed to peel
foods I thought you were supposed to
funeral ensues no you're supposed to
hold it you're not supposed to
before people had to clean it outdoors I
didn't do it I'm like when we went like
rafting and we weren't in the water like
you save it up and then like you hop and
you fear to say [ __ ] some waters like
how my warmth I'm a good thing I was
like beside you holding your hand or
just stayed in I think that's a great
place and the podcast I think of the
week you're right oh man it's fun to end
the podcast right there alright guys my
thing in the week has been saving our
booties yes so much this week it's so
great I bought it a long time ago is one
of these things that like when you need
it you need it and you're so glad you
have it it is a battery that you can
jump-start your car with and it's really
crazy because you can you know it's just
a battery like a little bit bigger than
my cell phone and it's made it has like
USB ports and that's power ports and you
can like charge certain types of laptops
on it too but it's not that big but the
great thing about it is you can jump
your car with this battery guys it's
ridiculous and our car has been dying a
lot so well and just practice it we sold
my car like late last year because we're
like okay we're working from home we
don't really need two cars and it's
never really gone in the way it's never
inconvenient almost at all but then when
the when the car died we're like well
crap yeah we did one you have no spare
you can't just say well I unless I also
take the other car and we'll deal with
this one later and you can't like you
can't jump it with your own car so it's
like yeah that's call someone or
whatever
but guys the crazy thing is is I hooked
up this battery and it jumped way faster
and way easier than if you had another
car it was so easy it's so easy it's
cumbersome yes less cumbersome you don't
have to worry about like like Oh car or
whatever the order is and then like you
start this car then start that car then
we need to rev it sometimes and
sometimes like you're not in a place
where another car can get near the hood
of your car and another thing is like
there is no sparks like cousin sometimes
when you're connecting the jumper cables
it's like Sparky Sparky and like it just
feels weird and this it was like
plugging it into a socket oh no I'm not
really and you still have the two clamps
but it was like so ridiculously easy and
it's just like I think even if you're
not a one car household you know most
people aren't I think every every used
to have one for each car yeah but I mean
like you have to charge it every now and
then you can come to the car adapter so
that when your car is good you can
charge the battery you using your car I
still think it's like super handy -
super handy yeah I I really have been
valuing it a lot yeah it's our cars died
like three or four times
we should probably either check the
terminals or take it in there what have
you there's going on a road trip yeah
yeah but we're gonna take the jumper
with us and if you need to jump it we
just jump it right there it's no big
deal yeah this is fine what's your thing
of the week I think week oh and we'll
put a link to the center another brand
yeah ours ours you can still buy it we
bought ours like two a year ago and it
still works great you can still buy it
but there's a newer version so all into
both okay um so my thing of the week is
an Instagram account um I think we first
started seeing someone beamed us well an
DM Gus but that's the first time we saw
it
oh you saw before and reddit I had seen
one or two clips but I didn't know who
the cat was on Reddit and it's but then
our friend an of anawalt raves deemed us
with their Instagram account because the
cat looks exactly like the supervisor
exactly I like the supervisor but the
people whose
the owners caretakers of the cat yeah
they so so the the cat is or the
Instagram account is Al Kitty like oh WL
kitty and what they do is like this
amazing video editing where they take my
cat and insert the cat into like clips
from movies so it'll be like a John wick
clip and the cat is edited in or like a
clip of like the royal couple people
with their own baby and but they're like
holding the cat instead and it's so well
done it's so well done it's it's amazing
I mean it definitely inspires me to like
do more with the green screen because
all of it is just like a nice green
screen and clever editing and now I
don't know how but he like often like
removes entire subjects from videos and
replaces it with al-qaeda so it's like
first removal and then like putting el
kitty and then matching the lighting
adding shadows all of that it's it's a
process it's so good I'm so impressed by
just like the amount of work it must
take to do those 10-second clips yeah
it's not but yeah it's very entertaining
very cute follow on Instagram and it the
kitty looks like the supervisor yeah
guys thanks so much for joining us on
another evident get in podcast this is
really enjoyable like kind of going into
these podcast episodes like a little bit
less planned like we did with today's
episode so let us know if you like that
and we'll see you next time
[Music]